If you enter in this Claude skill into
Claude code, it will create a beautiful
modern indexable and static blogging
website that you can customize to your
liking. And this is an example of what
the site will look like. It will be
modern. It will have your blog post. You
can have tutorials. You can have
workflows. And the most important part
is that it's going to be indexable.
We're using Astro as our build, so that
means it's going to be static HTML pages
that will actually index and do well on
Google. So, for example, I published
over to Netlify, so it's actually live
on the internet with a live URL.
And the prompt takes you through how to
do that. And I entered it into PageSpeed
Insights, and we can see here that we
got a 100 performance, uh
95 accessibility, 100 best practices,
and 100 SEO right out the gate. So, it's
lightning fast, this website. If we head
over to desktop, we can see we got a 97
performance on desktop. So, super super
fast, indexable. And this is the type of
website that will actually uh get
indexed and rank on Google. So, if you
wanted to use AI to expedite the time
that you can build, edit, and grow your
website, but you didn't want to build
something that's so code-heavy, this is
a solution for you. So, again, all you
need to do is comment website below, and
I'll send you over this full prompt. And
as you can see here, I entered in that
full prompt into Claude code. I then
told Claude code what I wanted to create
in terms of the type of website, the
type of theme in which I would like to
have, the feel of the website, and it
went ahead and built the website for me.
Once the website is Once the web Once
the website Once the
>> [clears throat]
>> Once Claude code has coded the website,
we then need to make the website live
either in your browser local environment
or on Netlify, which is going to be on
the internet. So, there's two main ways
in which you can go about doing so, and
this SOP walks you through exactly how
to do it using terminal, right? Using
terminal to then host so you can see
what it looks like on your local files,
but then also using Netlify to upload
the local files. So, essentially you'll
turn your code into a folder on your
local environment, head over to Netlify,
and then we're going to go to project,
and then we're going to want to add a
new project, and then we need to browse
files. So, we browse sorry our folder,
we choose the folder, and then you just
find that folder. As you can see, this
is the folder here. Open now you upload
that folder onto Netlify, and then it
will host your website on the internet,
and it's that easy to do so. We can go
back over to Netlify. As you can see,
we're on this project, head over to
domain management, add a domain, and you
can buy a domain, or you can add a
domain that you already own. So, I can
actually go ahead and just enter in any
new domain here that's available, and I
can have my site now have my custom
domain hosted on the internet. And if I
wanted to make changes, the best way to
do so is to connect this project over to
GitHub. So, any changes you made on um
on cloud code will then be changed to
GitHub, which will then trigger a new
build onto Netlify, and that's how you
can
automate the editing. And if you want to
add new features onto your website. So,
this is a really really simple but
effective and powerful flow that you can
use to create your own static HTML site.
If you guys want this prompt again, just
comment website below, and I'll send you
over the full prompt. I'll see you in
the next video. If you have any
questions, let me know in the comments
below. Take care.